hello in this video i explain to you
what the prerequisites for the variance
analysis are, strictly speaking, it's about
the basic form of the traffic
analysis, the one-factor real variance analysis of ms
repetition and so we start
right away from my previous video, you know
that the variant checks  whether there are
statistically significant differences
between more than two groups
let's briefly
recall the example that i might
be interested in, for example, whether there is
a difference in
the success of therapy after a herniated disc of
different therapies you could
just go through what with a group
what is good and what is bad about a
herniated disc a group
could treat it with medication
and with a group you could do the
strength exercises like this and with that
we start with the
requirements what are the
requirements for a variant analysis
we start with the scale level  that
level  the dependent variable should
metro seem that the independent
variable should be nominally escalated
so in our example we have on
the one hand the therapeutic success with
the three groups of talk therapy with
medication and exercise and strength
therapy this variable is of course
nominally escalated because we have the three
groups
On the other hand, we have the
dependent variable, the success of the therapy,
which, for example, goes from 1 to 10 and is
scaled metrically. The second
requirement is that the measurements should be
independent, i.e. the measured value from
one group should not be influenced by the
measured value from another
group, i.e. each  individual groups
are considered individually a
person from this group has no
influence on a person in this
group otherwise we would have a
dependent random sample if, for example, one person is
interviewed at three points in time but
that must not be
the third requirement is that the
variants of each group in  should be about the same
size
this can be checked with the help of the levin test
,
so the variance or the spread
within the group should be about the
same size and the last
requirement is that the data
should be normally distributed within the groups
we can do this as always  check
completely with a histogram or with a q of
course you can, as always,
easily
check the requirements for your data and
accomplices online to do this, simply go to date up de click on
the statistics calculator
select the test you
want to calculate is e.g. a variance analysis for
this  let's click on a metric
variable and a nominal variable
with more than two values, for
example the location, and then, as always, we
have the button check prerequisites here,
which we can simply click on
and then the result for
this will be output
to us in this case we certainly will  say
no, the requirements are not
met  t i hope you liked the video
if you like watch
the video how you
can calculate the variance analysis by hand
otherwise just watch the next
video in the playlist
bye and see you next time